Art has a very high status in modern societies:
People flock to museums
and art works fetch record prices.
But our age is also oddly reluctant to say in clear terms what art might actually be for.
An odd mystique surrounds it, epitomized by the puzzlement many of us feel
as we look at yet another odd looking, modern work of art in a contemporary museum.
We're often left quietly and politely wondering what is it all meant to be about.
For most of history, this kind of question didn't arise, because it was abundantly clear what art was for.
The question mark over the purpose of art is really a modern one, so let's go back in time
and find out about a wider range of options that we might be able to draw on fruitfully today.
Rome, 290 AD
Deep below the imperial Roman city, the faithful secretly gather in catacombs,
or burial chambers, to celebrate new religious figure, Jesus Christ.
Christianity, though still in its infancy and ruthlessly persecuted by the Roman authorities, is rapidly gaining ground.
Like so many religions before it and since, Christianity has become involved with the making of art.
Here, an unnamed and not especially talented artists represents Jesus healing of a bleeding woman,
an incident recorded in the New Testament.
Like all religions, Christianity is using art for a clear and understandable purpose:
to make its message more resonant, emotionally attractive, and popularly appealing.
Art is like a kind of advertising for
its ideas.
Soon Christian artists are going to dominate
Europe.
For almost a thousand years almost all art produced in Europe will
simply be Christian art.
From humble beginnings in a subterranean prayer room,
Christian art will go on to produce
extraordinary cathedrals, paintings
sculptures and celebrating and enhancing
the prestige of its messages.
Thailand, 15th century
An unknown
craftsman finishes a statue of the Buddha.
One of many hundreds of thousands
of such statues produced over the
centuries in Southeast Asia.
The purpose of such art is extremely
clear:
You're meant to look at the Buddha and take inspiration, becoming a little
more as he is.
The sculpture is an invitation to calm
and contemplation.
In the East as in the West arts function is evident:
to support the truths set down by religions,
to make ideas more easily
digestible.
Paris, January 1801
The French artist Jacques-Louis David finishes "Napoleon crossing the Alps".
It commemorates a moment when a couple of years before, Napoleon still in his
twenties launched a lightning raid on
the North Italian states, winning a series of astonishing victories.
In the picture, Napoleon masters a white warhorse
though he
actually cross the mountains on a more serviceable mule.
Here, art is doing something it has done
throughout history as well:
acting as propaganda for a political
cause.
Napoleon is looking back to the example
of Louis XIV of France who
did a lot of propagandizing with art.
It was a habit he got into throughout his rule.
Paris, 1833
The poet, novelist and critique Théophile Gautier publishes an essay about art,
which argues that art must free itself from the poisonous agendas of religions and governments.
The point of good art is always to be just for its own sake
as he put it in French, "l'art pour l'art", art for art's sake.
This doctrine of art for art's sake
becomes the motto of the new generation of romantic artists
who set themselves
against the old ideal that art should serve religion or powerful rulers or
nations.
Nonsense, says  Gautier,  true art must serve nothing at all.
it is an end in itself and doesn't try
to change or do or speak about anything.
Artists set themselves apart from the
bourgeois commercial society growing up all around,
which is always trying to sell
people things.
Art should try to inhabit a loftier, more abstract realm.
New York, 1917
The artist Marcel Duchamp
prepares to exhibit his latest work at a show by the Society of Independent
Artists.
It is surprisingly a urinal titled
simply Fountain.
Duchamp is a rebellion against many notions of what
art is,
that it should be easy to understand, that it should make sense,
that it should promote something.
The true artist, argues Duchamp must
defend himself against any confusion
with advertising, mass media, government
propaganda or religious indoctrination,
that true purpose of the artist is to
stand outside the mainstream and create
works that are enigmatic, mysteriously
provocative and rather silent.
New York, 1949
A russian émigré artist, Marcus Ravkovic who has renamed himself Mark Rothko to escape anti-semitism
exhibits a new range of works at the
Betty Parsons gallery in Manhattan.
They are a revelation,  in that they seem not to be about anything.
They are about pure color fields and are as abstract as music.
For some, they are the greatest works of the 20th century and soon fetch
enormous prices.
The Museum of Modern Art acquires a
major set of Rothko's as do other national museums around the world.
Rothko becomes representative of the
more obscure direction of 20th century art,
highly appealing to an elite who
will often pay enormous incomprehensible prices for works
but puzzling for the
wider public.
Venice, June 2005
The world's most prestigious
art fair, The Venice Biennale opens at the newly restored spaces of the Arsenale.
It has been curated for the first time
by two women,  María de Corral and Rosa Martinez.
41 artist's are shown from
all over the world.
The nearby Marco Polo airport is filled
with the private jets of the world's billionaires,
many of whom profess to
love art.
Elaborate cocktail parties are held late into the night.
Art has become a playground for the
super rich
as well as an obligatory tourist destination for weary travelers.
Art is both hugely revered and yet
somehow still in question.
For most of its history art has been saddled with a mission:
to glorify religion or to speak well of the state.
Modern art was the result of a swerve
away from these agendas for extremely understandable reasons.
Yet if art is to regain its true centerality
it should overcome it hesitation about
stating what it's really for and is trying to do.
It is really and has always
been a sophisticated tool,
a tool that can help us to cope with things like loneliness,
that can fill us with hope,
that can help us to communicate our inner world,
that questions power and aims to improve political systems.
It is never an insult to ask art to do
things for us,
to be a practical part of our daily lives.
We honor art most when
we give it the highest task of all:
to help us to lead better lives.
If you like our films take a look at our
shop.
theschooloflife.com/shop
You'll find lots of thoughtful books, games, stationery and more.